hello everyone
Sal here sorry this is a very makeshift
situation that we're dealing with I've
moved locations yesterday the internet
connection wasn't so good I think it was
because I was away from the Wi-Fi router
so now I'm in my mother-in-law's bedroom
who lives with us and it is closer to
the Wi-Fi router so hopefully all of
this is going to be a little bit
smoother today so welcome I guess you
could say live stream some people have
started calling you to a home room of
sorts just to get us started on the day
for those of you who are new the goal of
this is really just to be a resource for
parents for teachers and for students
all of us are trying to navigate this
whole situation that we find ourselves
in where we have school closures around
the country and around the world
I think I saw data yesterday that
there's 900 points around the world that
would normally be in school but who
aren't in school right now and all of us
at Khan Academy we realized that this we
would have never foreseen this type of a
situation but we kind of exist to help
out a situation like this so all of our
entire team at Khan Academy I really
want to thank everyone on Khan Academy
team and all the supporters of Khan
Academy and our volunteers and our
teacher ambassadors for really stepping
up over the last few days you know I've
been mentioning this every day but some
of the core resources that we've been
putting out other than doing this daily
live stream or homeroom if you will
we've been putting out teacher webinars
to help teachers get signed up we've
been seeing record number of
registrations of teachers it looks like
some might even be a factor of 10 at
least that's what one of my team members
told me earlier this morning we're
seeing a record number of registrations
parents who are running parent webinars
to help parents get set up over the
weekend we realized that you know we
have a lot of resources at Khan Academy
that cover all of the major subjects and
grades but
parents and teachers who are now looking
to kind of virtualize our need to know
how do i structure the day so it kind of
feels like school and obviously this is
a substitute for it and this is a very
suboptimal situation so we released
schedules that work for students as
young as pre-k going into kindergarten
first second grade then we have a
schedule for elementary age schedule for
middle and high school and then
scheduled for later high school across
subjects and grades so that people know
how to structure their day and it's not
just you know do this thing on Khan
Academy or that thing on Khan Academy
there break scheduled in there's even
some resources we like a recess one of
my family friends immediately when when
she saw that it had yoga with adriene on
it and just dance she took my favorite
exercise activities when I'm when it's a
rainy day and I can't go outside so yes
I add a little bit of editorial
influence but those are resources for
all of you we're doing this live stream
expect over the coming days and weeks to
see more live streams that may be spawn
off of this we are exploring ways to
provide teachers and students and
parents more supports one idea that
we've talked about it I talked about
this yesterday is as you go through
those schedules leveraging Khan Academy
and other resources if teachers could
set up a webinar or video conferencing
for their students that way the students
could log in while they're say working
on Khan Academy math or biology and then
ask questions students could also self
organize around that and if folks are
still just getting off the ground and
parents could also the thing I really
want to emphasize for everyone is you
know don't stress out about the
situation we're really just in the
beginning of a situation that's very new
to all of us and so even if it takes
several days you know going into next
week to get everyone into a rhythm
that's completely understandable in my
house we have that situation I had to
push my children outside as they were
screaming over fighting over a chair for
eating breakfast so this is an
interesting situation for all of us and
you know we just saw news last night
we've been talking about something like
this that
if you just look at the what's been
happening in other countries and when
you might hit peak virus or peak
infection it looks like it's going to be
more than just a few weeks several
school districts the team tells me I
think Kansas I'm gonna make sure I'm
getting that right announced announced
if Kansas is the first state to close
schools for the rest of the academic
year we have about two two and a half
months in the academic year and so that
probably will be extended for a lot of
folks so I think all of us need to
figure out how do we work together to
make sure that everyone keeps learning
not just through the rest of the
academic year but then we can leverage
summer as well to keep that learning so
that as we go into the new school year
where hopefully everything is fine by
then we everyone is ready and and
capable and and to engage and if for
whatever reason this whole situation
comes back where we know how to switch
between these modalities quite fast so
let me look at some questions that are
here so one question was are we able to
meet increased demands or even are we
seeing increased demands what the team
at Khan Academy has told me on Monday we
saw 50% increase in traffic from the
Monday previous and it looks like
Tuesday yesterday was even higher than
Monday and so we're still looking at the
data but it looks like there's a pretty
dramatic increase in demand and
obviously there's an increased demand
for this type of thing for us to be able
to help people navigate the entire
crisis I want to make a huge shout out
for those of you haven't seen it there
was a press release last night Bank for
America I want to thank operation to
step up we've had a long-standing
relationship with Bank for America
they've been the main partner for our
financial literacy content for a career
content over the past seven years and
they've you know the reason why I kind
of kind of even has been able to step up
in this crisis is because of many years
of support from folks like Bank of
America but as soon as a Thursday and
Friday of last week they saw that this
is going to be a bit of a situation
around the school closures they
immediately saw
us as a really instrumental part of this
and they called us up and said what can
we do to help we want to make sure that
the America and the world can keep
learning and over the weekend they've
provided resources for Khan Academy so
that we can keep our servers up so we
can do this type of livestream we're
kind of calling it a national or
international homeroom they've provided
there they're going to help provide
awareness so that parents teachers
students around the country who might
not be aware of Khan Academy or the
resources we're providing over this over
this I guess you'd call it social
distancing that that were able to
provide more of those resources that we
have the aperture to think bigger about
how we can solve things and they also
have a lot of really good partnerships
with other nonprofits school districts
solve parts of the situation because
Khan Academy is a part of it
we have obviously we can do things
online we have all this content all of
the software but above and beyond that
we want to look to partner with folks to
ensure that all students can have access
to things like internet right now that's
valuable not just for Khan Academy but
it's also I think important in this time
of social distancing to be able to have
some social interaction that's you know
not traditional social media but you can
also interact with people and things
like that so thank you so much to Bank
of America for being you know in record
time stepping up to support Khan Academy
so that we can support so many others
and helping the support directly so I'd
love to answer y'all's questions let's
see I can look at this stream down here
and I can see what the team is surfacing
to me so there is one question let's see
how do I figure out what my child should
be learning so there's a couple of ways
to think about this I actually had a
really great conversation some of you
might have seen the video with Tim
Vandenberg who is great math teacher and
Hesperian California
I also learned yesterday he's the number
two monopoly player in the in the
country or the world there's a
documentary about him apparently so he's
an impressive
all around and I was thought monopoly
was mostly luck but he's like can you
always beat me in monopoly he's like yes
I will pretty much always be doing then
he said my sixth graders will be good
monopoly so cannot believe and frankly
if I if we can figure out a way to bring
in remote guests on this livestream I
would love to bring Tim in but the
reason why I brought up to him is he has
some really great ways to work with
students gaps in their knowledge because
there there is there's kind of two views
one view to say okay we're about 3/4
through the school year so therefore
maybe we should be exactly 3/4 through
whatever grade level your child is
working on and there's a lot of truth to
that what Tim Vandenberg has seen is
that a lot of his students as they've
gone at a at a at a fixed pace for all
students they might get a B in one
concept so they have a ten percent gap
but seeing another concept of a twenty
percent gap and those gaps keep
accumulating and that's why when he gets
them in sixth grade oftentimes they have
trouble engaging in that grade level
material and so what he does is he has
all of his students these are sixth
graders started kindergarten on Khan
Academy and do our act to our early
learning section on Khan Academy and our
arithmetic section on Khan Academy and
our third grade those are the three that
he says he has some focus on and then
simultaneously he also tries them he
tries to get them to complete unit by
unit at sixth grade so they're able to
be on grade level and make sure they
have all their gaps filled and in his
school and his school 90% of the
students that come to him are well below
grade level so it's super important for
him but what he finds is is by allowing
some time for the students to remediate
or fill in those gaps they're more
likely to really master the concepts at
the grade level as well so this is just
a long-winded way of saying you should
absolutely talk to your student or if
you are the student think about where
you are in the year you can start on
those units on Khan Academy but given
that we have more flexibility right now
given your school day is really defined
by you and your parents and and your
teachers that that you could you can
especially in math you can spend a
little bit more extra time where you can
do things at your grade level learned
that if your own
having pasted on Khan Academy so if
you're a sixth grader work on the sixth
grade math you could take the course
challenge the course challenge will take
you about 30 or 40 minutes but it'll
accelerate the things that you already
know and then the things you're having
difficulty with you can go to those
units and then you can take the unit
tests there and then on those unit tests
when you take those you can learn what
skills you might need help on and if you
do that in sixth grade and then it
wouldn't be a bad idea to set some other
time maybe another half an hour a day
where you start with early early math on
Khan Academy go into go into the
arithmetic go into third grade to really
make sure you have your basics and you
can use things like the course
challenges in the unit tests and the
mastery challenges to accelerate through
it so it's not going to take you a lot
of time if you already know all of the
materials so let me look at other other
courses and another thing about the
schedule another like you know what what
to work on during the year I think it's
important to realize this is for parents
as well that if if you the student or
either parent as long as the student can
focus on the Foundation's and really
master it so we you know what I've been
telling the press lately is you know we
have these schedules that can fill up
most of what would be the traditional
school hours but if you at least do two
hours a day an hour of reading an hour
of math that will get your basics those
those skills won't won't atrophy you'll
you know your reading comprehension will
keep up and your and and your math
skills won't go away but ideally you're
able to look at a schedule like what we
what we published and modify it to your
own needs obviously and and hopefully
make you some give us feedback on that
questions is it okay if I put up a pic
of you students want to know how you
look I don't think I could stop you from
doing that you know they might be
disappointed when they see what I really
look like but I'll defer to you you're
the educator that's if that's a good
idea
okay Chandra Pok a park sorry
Chandra Park asks
would there be live academic classes on
Khan Academy I saw some live SAT math
classes on YouTube in the past and I was
wondering if this is something that's
going to be something especially because
of COFA 19 Chandra we are exploring
doing things like that exactly you're
exactly right in the past for things
like SCT and apt Bernards live live live
streams and our team is exploring how we
can do that I'm I also want our folks
who do write you know create video
conference software are there ways to to
get people into video conferencing
groups so that they can also help each
other so we can do these larger scale
live streams whether it's from me or
other teachers or content creators and
then it would also be great if we could
find ways for folks to connect with each
other and answer each other's questions
so simple answer is yes the plan is is
there we're hopefully will you'll start
seeing some of that stuff by a next week
or even at the end of this week okay
let's see is it says on Facebook we saw
a lot of comments about pursuing
passions and hobbies is that in the
schedule how important is that so you
know this this is passions and hobbies
are super important thing and in some
way it is you know you could view this
situation we find ourselves in as glass
half-full I think especially as you get
into high school a lot of students and
if I'm if you are student I'll talk to
you a lot of you are you know we would
traditionally have a lot on your plate
you have you're taking six classes
you're doing all these extracurricular
activities you're you're taking the SAT
you're studying for AP tests you're
applying to college it can be pretty
stressful now all of a sudden a lot of
that is cleared out and so I think this
is a really powerful time for you to
keep on your academics and that's where
we've really got to help you and also
think you have time to pursue your
passions it might be creating videos it
might be writing it might be software it
might be dance and I think you know
creativity is oftentimes the byproduct
of boredom it's you have a little bit of
time on your hands now really think
about what what motivates you and you
know this whole crisis that we're all
going through together there's a lot of
new problems that I think need to be
solved and so if you're a student think
about how you would solve those problems
are there you know new types of things
you can invent that will lower the
spread of the virus or that can help
people are there ways you know are there
volunteer efforts that you could do even
while people are socially distance to
make sure that maybe members of your
community who might be living alone
might not have as much support that they
are feeling a connection with other
people or that you know they feel
supported or people can help them with
their groceries and things like that
there's things we have to think about it
with the economy you know I'm very
fortunate I'm continuing to get my
salary because I can do my work remotely
there's a lot of folks that now that
there's the social distancing in place
you know California where I live is now
in full you know stay in place orders
there's a lot of people who aren't able
to make their living right now so are
there creative ideas to how we help some
of those folks so yeah I think this is a
great time for your passions and you can
almost you could really view this as a
bit of a opportunity see other questions
keep coming to relog let's see so Sonia
Torborg says Sal you talked about
eliminating the Swiss cheese analogy of
math education lots of holes in one's
understanding once lawyers gain mastery
of certain math concepts is their way of
learning the knowledge and unlocking
more practical tasks or challenges or
math projects it would be cool to embed
it in the site where easter-egg like
challenges for kids to unlock thoughts l
asagna what you're describing is
something we would love to do and I hope
we can do over time and you know I was
talking about Tim Vanderburgh and I
talked about his methodology uses but
he's been seeing incredible results
where pretty much every every one of us
he starts the year ninety percent of
students aren't at grade level he sees
pretty much here where ninety percent of
the students are grade level or above by
the end of the year by making sure that
his students can fill in the Swiss
cheese gaps and I'll ask the team to put
the link to the Tim Bandar Berg video
all right you webinar that we had below
in our description or in our live stream
someplace because it not only is it
inspiring for teachers to see what Tim's
done I think it can be very inspiring
for parents to allocate of an
opportunity we can do this at home a
leverage the Khan Academy a total
hopefully inspiring for students to say
oh maybe this is why I've been having
trouble in algebra it's not because I'm
not bright it's not because algebra is
difficult it's because I had all these
gaps accumulating and what Tim says even
sixth grade or seventh graders you start
them on that early math or a great math
arithmetic they almost always discover
even the ones that are a or B students
some of the ones who are performing at
grade level they discover that they had
they had some gaps that with mathematics
and so let's see the see Michael Toscano
says it's probably old at this point but
this tile of video really puts the home
in homeroom yes you're right this is
literally a room in my home that is
correct
I think stuff going on in her work there
you know it doesn't get exposed somehow
and obviously have three kids and I have
to say by the older too
our school is doing kind of engage in
his work so yeah it's interesting times
I definitely empathize and you know it's
one of these times where it's a lot of
gratitude and thankful you know it makes
you appreciate a lot of the small things
I went to the grocery store this morning
at 6:00 a.m. which is when it opened I
figured that's going to be the best time
but you could imagine it was already it
was there it was already an interesting
place to be but you know I felt
fortunate to even be able to go so let's
see other questions is Khan Academy's
from Noland fisherman it's kind of kind
of me enough to study for the AP exam B
what is other questions that people have
see just a lot of nice people okay
apparently I'm lagging I'm sorry I'm a
give me feedback this is closer to my
Wi-Fi router you'll see let's see do see
if someone says do you think scientists
will find a cure for kovat 19 if so when
do you think they'll find it I'm not an
epidemiologist I'm not a biologist I'm
so take all this with a grain of salt
but I've taught some of the things
viruses and things on Khan Academy okay
I don't think any of us really know
including many of the experts at this
point we can only hope there are some
early reports of doctors using
tales of existing drugs that have been
used for other things like malaria or
AIDS that might have some promise to it
who knows it's just you're getting such
disjointed reports from different parts
of the world with very different
mortality rates and infection rates and
obviously the testing is a big issue the
number one thing all of us can do is
minimize contact with with physical
contact right now to try to stay with
your family you know I'm really glad
that California where I live
decide to make the hard decision I'm
going to stay in place order it's hard
you know it has to be in their house
they are allowing that you can go
outside if you want to go for a run but
even then they say you know make sure
you keep distance from people but this
is the kind of action you need to do and
you know in any type of epidemiological
response if you do the right thing it
will look like you you you are overly
cautious but if you aren't overly
cautious then you see these things grow
exponentially and then it's very hard to
stop and you know the United States it's
we are in an unfortunate situation where
the testing isn't where it needs to be
and so you know I posted a video that
the likely cases are far higher are
likely far higher it's like almost for
sure or higher than the reported cases
and so it's very prudent that you know
in our area the seven counties for seven
million people they did the stay in
place order and I think that'll be
useful for for much of the rest of the
world
obviously it has economic implications
etc etc but it's much better than it
things in the bud and I'm you know it
might be a little bit past the bud stage
right now so we will see how we're all
through this together this is really
interesting time it's a great time to
learn about what a virus is what DNA is
what RNA is listen to the news you'll
learn a lot about how the economy works
because people are realizing okay
there's certain roles where people are
able to have income but there's other
parts of our economy where people
already didn't have a lot of money but
they're you know they're getting hourly
pay now the restaurants and our air all
over the restaurants are closed except
for takeout how how are the owners gonna
have money to pay them and if they don't
have money how are they going to be able
to even you know get the bear the basic
necessities they need or pay rent so
there's all sorts of interesting ideas
that people are starting to float on how
to get everyone through this but I've
been I've been proud just to see how
most people have been acting in the
active interest which i think is really
really really powerful see maybe time
for a few more questions I started late
and III really enjoyed this this is this
is almost you know a little bit for for
for my sanity as well it feels really
nice to feel even virtually connected
with all of you because I'm also
socially distanced let's see let's the
other let's see let's the other other
question someone said well you get into
the engineering field we have some
content on electrical engineering on
Khan Academy now in the near term we
probably won't go deep into the
engineering field but you know long term
I hope one day we can do some of the
basics of some of the engineering fields
let's see other other other someone said
see other questions asking do any plans
on expanding concrete higher studies of
like engineering a lot of people want
engineering see other questions I'll go
to see what the team might have surfaced
as well I'll see those there are a lot
of comments coming in on on social media
as well so do you
Annamarie asked do you have things for
early learning before first grade so
Anna Kahn Academy kids it's available on
Android and on iOS it's free go download
it what you'll see is you know when you
see most apps or especially that age
group they just do one thing this is
this app has a little bit of a universe
inside of it has over 100 books have
hundreds of videos and they're
interactive videos where there'll be a
song and a dance and then they'll stop
and they'll ask your child or your
student to do something it's it's
appropriate for students as early as Age
3 in fact I would say even potentially
for Age 2 you know for that age group
it's always best to be able to do it
next to or on the lap of a loved one you
know a parent and uncle aunt a
grandparent older sibling but if they're
able to do 20 minutes 30 minutes a day I
think they'll really enjoy it and we've
seen some promising efficacy studies
around it and it'll get them you know it
starts with letters numbers colors
social-emotional learning but
all the way through the head start
standards the kindergarten Common Core
standards in the first grade Common Core
standard so if you start your child on
it starting age three say it has plenty
of runway for them and it can keep them
busy for one it adapts to them based on
what they know and what they don't know
so highly highly encourage that that's
why we created Khan Academy kids have
you've seen downloads go up last I heard
from our team 505 fold they typically
are so hopefully you know people are
people are making people are one foot in
front of their are representing other
companies